special for Netflix you did a lot of  characters for that yes I did I did I'm  gonna go and you did impressions for  that show right I did well I did more  characters I do do impressions in my  stand-up I have a Britney Spears of  iconic you have a Britney Spears it is  iconic  yeah oh it's an iconic impression Oh  credible yeah can we hear it a little  bit yes okay  but I will I will thank you but I do  take requests just so that everyone  knows it's not rigged here's the thing  here's the thing I don't do toxic it's  too fast and you won't hear the nuances  of the impression lucky lucky I love  lucky and what a sad song that came true  for her so edit for right now the kind  of melancholy feeling in there I think  it'll be perfect  sure ready go for it okay okay well the  intro she comes on stage this is a story  about a girl named Lucky  [Laughter]  thank you so much  [Applause]  you